this is a production of cornell
university
okay hello i'm susan brown i lead the
apple breeding program at cornell
university
i'm the hermann m coen professor of
agriculture and life sciences i've been
here since 1985 have released a number
of cherries
a tart cherry and several apples
and i'm standing next to two of my
babies which are snapdragon and ruby
frost they were grown exclusively in new
york state by our growers but now have
been opened up and are being trialled
around the world and as an apple breeder
nothing is better than saying your
apples in the grocery store
or having people say they're my favorite
apple
what i love about apples
is that they are they just want to be
diverse so when you're breeding wheat or
corn or rice you want a uniform stand
you want not one
you know a stalk higher than another but
apples are naturally out crossing which
means genetically they have to produce
and get pollinated by something that's
not genetically related that's exciting
but it makes for a lot of variation
that's how they've survived for millions
of years what we do is every time we
find a really unusual plant we spade it
and we bring it to this place
and
growers from other countries have said
i'm either crazy or a genius and i
haven't wanted it to go to a vote
but i think you'll find some things that
are interesting okay as i said there's
tremendous diversity in apples this is
malice domestica the commercial apple
but i want to give you a snapshot of
what other diversity there exists with
other malice species
things that you never thought you would
see within an apple tree i am not a
master of bonsai
these are genetically dwarfed trees that
are at least 12 to 14 years old
their sister seedlings are 25 30 feet
tall this is on their own roots
and most breeders throw these away
but they're linked to genes of
importance and the more we understand
about that linkage the more we can
genetically improve this is another
architectural type type called weeping
it was mapped
with collaboration with kanangju and his
group
to linkage group 13
and as you can see it cascades over for
machine harvesting some of these unique
architectural types
will give us insight in how to breed
the perfect tree for mechanical
harvesting home use etc this is a
columnar mutation
and we call it columnar because it has
reduced branching although this has a
lot of branches and you can see that the
the leaf type is very big
this actually has white double flowers
is spectacular and bloom
and
we are learning more about what causes
branches to be upright versus straight
and for the ornamental market there's a
lot of interest in this particular
accession most apple trees
want to grow upright
but these just want to grow horizontally
in in russia breeders have been using
this where they could grow the trees
under the snow line
and keep the trees hardy because of the
snow cover
so this is a columnar that we crossed by
a variety called our species called
malice de mariai
and when my graduate student at the time
was showing me pictures he only had
pictures of the mother tree in a
greenhouse
so i said why is that and he said i
don't know and i said well look it up
after we had planted hundreds of these
in the field it's also called formosa
apple so it's not native here not
adapted here we took a chance when we
planted some of these we wanted the very
serrated beautiful leaves that are shiny
and we wanted to see if we could get
columnar habit in these leaves and this
particular species is used for cosmetics
for skin and he had saying youth
promoting chemicals and we were able to
prove that in one generation we could
get something that would survive upstate
winners and so it shows for climate
change we're not as limited as we
thought we would be
okay would you guess that that's an
apple tree
so with the leaves that i've shown you
earlier would you believe that this is
an apple tree or a giant rosemary plant
that we decided to grow
this is a very unique plant in that it
contains compounds that are very
beneficial for diabetes control and are
being actually used for diabetes
treatment
most red leafed material is like this
it's red at the tip and then it fades
and we weren't quite sure
why that was
oh sorry and i'll then walk this way
but now
we have not only red coloration that's
staying but interesting lobed leaves
the blossoms of this are red some of
them are single some of them are double
but we feel that it's an important niche
in the uh
ornamental marker
this is when you do your happy dance
i've never seen a crab apple like this
in terms of intensity of color
the
lobed leaves the fact that it's almost
maroon and then for ornamentals you want
the fruit to be very small and not
create a tripping hazard
but provide some food for wildlife so
this is
the absolute perfect specimen karas
and this is an example of why do we care
about what is in centers of origin
this is derived from something called
malice nudesvitskiana it's related to
one of the first apples that ever
existed and this characteristic red
color
is only found in nudes with scanner and
its derivatives
and
recently
other breeders are looking to produce
red fleshed apples
for not only eating obviously much
larger than this
but also for rose cider
and there's a lot of very healthy
compounds but there's some astringency
and acidity that has not made it my
priority in breeding but the other
variability is that almost every apple
cluster sets five or six
flowers
and in the
center of the flower is called the king
and just like in life it's good to be
king
so you want it's the biggest fruit it's
the best fruit
now naturally all these apples would be
set and an apple always produces more
blossoms and more flowers
to produce fruit than they can handle
this year because of drought
and a number of frosts instead of seeing
fruit covering this tree
you're seeing an apple here or there
and that's kind of disastrous for our
growers it's going to mean these apples
are amazing so they're going to be very
big they're going to be delicious but
there's not going to be enough of them
so those are some of the challenges that
we face other challenges
are things like
powdery mildew
give it its name because it looks like
somebody sprinkled powdery uh powdered
sugar on the tip and so these are all
the things as a breeder i have to
consider but what i consider first and
foremost in my program is consistency of
quality
and so we know that if you
get a banana you want that banana to
taste the same if you could catch it at
that perfect stage of ripeness
with apples we want to make sure that
they're consistent but a tree as you can
see is very variable you'll have
different branches we're trying to farm
the sun
and by doing that we want to make sure
that the apples on top that are getting
a lot of sun are as uh
as good or these are as
good or better um when they're in the
shade as you can see that an apple is
sensitive to sun the color is going to
be where the sun hits it
where the sun doesn't hit it is where
it's going to be green
or where a leaf covers it or
where
something else covers it
when i started this job i asked growers
kids my family what do you like about an
apple what do you want to change
and the growers were like watch out for
the stem it's like what what do you mean
watch out for the stem
well so this is a nice long stem
if it's too short it pushes off the tree
if it's too long it can swing and hit
but if it's with another apple in the in
the bin that stem
serves as a puncture point so
things that you never even think about
the bottom of the apple
pink lady has a very open calyx and
fungus can get through
so what i love about my job is whether
it's climate change or
increasing vitamin c or
compounds related to diabetes control
we get to learn something and every
piece of information that we have so we
have a published genome we have a lot of
molecular markers we have a lot of
people working on
many of the same things
but the more we know the more there is
to discover
and if you're a
picture puzzle junkie as my family are
just as you think you have the puzzle
piece you want it doesn't quite fit
and we have to figure out a way around
it by collaboration
and so i'm fortunate that we've had
varieties that have been very well
accepted
but we also have some things that i
think are going to blow the minds of the
next generation so you and the audience
are going to have ideas about okay what
does this mean what if we see this
particular phenotype what does that mean
genetically and why should we care
and if you want to get funding as a
graduate student or as a new researcher
if you can't explain to people why they
should care you're not going to get that
funding
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu